if you know your Old Testament he just
claimed to be Yahweh
God did the disciples understand that at
the time is that we you give them too
much credit yeah because I just all
throughout the gospels the disciples are
getting glimpses but then they're being
perplex and blown away yeah because I
just I think I read something either
today or yesterday that was like a lot
of them didn't even like realize what he
was really saying about him claiming to
be God they were shocked now they got
glimpses of it sometimes the light
switch went on and they realize he's not
an ordinary man because he's doing
things only God could do but then
reality kicked in and said no no he's
you know can't
be so did they think he was just like a
teacher at the time well not just a
teacher they're realizing he's more than
a teacher and he's claiming things that
only God can claim but they don't know
how to process it so they're left
baffled and confused and scandalized
till the very end until after the
resurrection then this light light
switch went
on yeah then yeah we were right he was
claiming things only God can can
say and yet we had a hard time
processing that because we were seeing a
man a flesh and blood Jew and we know
he's not the father so we were
correcting seeing that he's claiming to
be God but we couldn't understand how
that can be true if he's not the father
and he's a
man they were struggling with
that that's should to shock you everyone
struggles with that even when you as a
baby Christian you struggle with the
Trinity and how Christ can be God in man
oh yeah for sure I still so unless you
think these guys came from down from
heaven with Supra intelligence that's
beyond
any human mind they were humans like us
and they were fishermen they're not even
educated rabbis they were not taught the
depth of theology they were not steeped
in philosophy I'm talking about the
initial disciples we not talking about
Paul he comes later so they were simple
people who had a simple faith and as far
as they knew God is not a man and no Jew
can be God the god of Abraham but here's
a man who's not the father because he
keeps telling he Son of God and he's a
flesh and blood Jew but he says things
done things that only God can do but how
can that be because we know God is not a
man and as far as we know God is the
Father in heaven so they're processing
this slowly but
surely and when they're getting the
glimpse of him being
God it takes them a back because their
worldview hasn't prepared them for that
reality m
why do you think there are times in
which they freak out and they get
scared that's s he does let me show you
you
ready you sure you
ready yeah how ready are you as ready as
can be I guess right let me show you one
second never mind I'll find one more
like you okay ready yep let me show you
two versions Matthew 8 version right
here verses 23- 27 I'll show you the
mark in version right guys pay attention
because they know from the Old Testament
God Almighty is Sovereign over the winds
and the waves and the Seas of the
elements and he controls them
effortlessly
right now watch and when he got in the
boat Matthew
82327 his disciples followed him and
behold there arose a great storm on the
sea great storm on the sea so that the
boat was being covered with waves but
Jesus himself was sleeping they came and
got up got him up saying save us Lord we
are perishing we're perishing
now these are trained fishermen if a
trained fisherman starts screaming we're
about to perish he's trained he knows
the sees better than us if he panics
freaks out get ready to meet your
maker right yeah so they they know that
boys it's it's over with we're about to
die and meet meet God so they're
screaming save us Lord we're perishing
we wouldn't react this way if it wasn't
serious because we are fisherman we know
we're in a no in situation we're about
to capsize and we're going to meet right
like uh that like the mafia say lucab
bratzi is sleeping with the fishes you
know what that
means that he's dead in the ocean yeah
lucab brzi you know the mafia that means
they killed him and they buried his body
in the
sea so L is sleeping with the fishes
meaning they killed him got rid of his
body and dumped it in the
sea where the fishes are you get it mhm
so there Peter's about to say John we're
about to sleep with the fishes
homie you know you get it yeah now watch
her so they're freaking out right save
us Lord we're perishing now imagine you
when you read the Bible play out like a
screen and you're there Envision the
reaction so the reaction isn't and I
don't want to be too loud I don't want
my neighbors this not the reaction
Guys these are real historical events
they're really about to capsize and they
really think they're going to drown so
imagine you're them so it's not like
this is not their reaction save us Lord
we're
perishing Lord do you not care we're
perishing they're freaking out they're
screaming save us we're about to
die right they're reacting that way you
get the point guys
play it out that's how they're reacting
really that's how they're reacting right
you're not gonna be save save us Lord
don't you care okay now that said watch
their reaction when they see his
power okay save us Lord we are perishing
and he said to them why are you so
cowardly you men of little faith then he
got up rebuked the winds and the Sea and
it perfectly became perfectly calm now
watch and the men marveled and said what
kind of man is this that even the winds
and the Seas obey him see they freaking
out who is this
man how the hell is he able to control
the winds and seas this power belongs to
God from the Old Testament and there are
a lot of passages Psalm 65 verses 5 to8
Psalm 77: 19- 20 write it down Psalm 65:
5 to8 Psalm
77: 19 to 20 Psalm
10721 you can start at 21 or 22 to 31 or
all the way to 32 depends where you want
to end it Psalm 107 will go
22-32 job 9 ver8 this is a power
attributed to God how the hell is he
able to do this he's just the
man you see they're like freaking out
now watch the Markin
version watch the Markin
version uh can I ask a quick question
yes so if Mark is the oldest this um
gospel written why is it or like why is
it ordered Matthew and then Mark that's
because modern scholarship sets mark
That's not the early Church's view
that's why I said if you believe Mark is
first the ancient Church said Mar
Matthew wrote his gospel first but now
it's a little tricky according to the
early church Matthew wrote Jesus's
sayings loia in Aramaic and it says he
wrote the Gospel in Aramaic
later on it was translated in Greek so
you can actually make a case that what
Matthew originally wrote was the Gospel
in Aramaic then Mark would have come and
written his gospel and then maybe later
on Matthew wrote a Greek version oh okay
all right but now you saw the Matthew
version right yeah watch the Markin
version Mark
43541 and on that day when evening came
he said to them let us go over to the
other side leaving the crowd they took
him along with them in the boat just as
he was and other Boats were with him and
a great Windstorm arose and the waves
were breaking into the boat it's about
to capsize so that the boat was already
filling up and Jesus himself was in the
stern sleeping on the cushion they got
him up and said to him teacher do you
not care that we are perishing and he
woke up rebuked the wind and said to the
Sea silence be still the wind died down
and it became perfectly calm and he said
to them why are you so cowardly do you
still have no faith now watch their
reaction they became very
afraid they started freaking out see it
yeah they now are freaking out they're
terrified at what he just did and we're
saying to one another who then is this
you see they're freaking out who is he
really who is this
man who is he that he's able to do what
only God can do that even the wi and
they say obey him so you guys understand
the point I'm making to the brother
right that I'm making to the brother
they're getting glimpses he's no
ordinary
man he's doing things saying things that
from our Old Testament only God can say
and do but he's a man he's a Jew and
he's not the father and we've been
accustomed to speak of the father as God
are we properly understanding what we're
seeing it can't be he left them baffled
perlex perplexed and Confused they don't
know how to handle this because they can
see he's not a mere man they know he's
not the father and they see he's doing
things and saying things only God can do
but they're not able to process that
because no way can't be no no no no no
hey uh it's like Peter looking at Thomas
did did we just see him just do what we
just saw him do yeah but uh Thomas you
remember in
uh Saturday school because they didn't
have Sunday school they observe Sabbath
right sat Saturday school you know I
have Sunday school they had Saturday
school Sabbath didn't the rabbis read
from the Scrolls that Yahweh alone has
this
power
yeah and yet he has this
yeah are you seeing what I'm seeing is
this Our God In the
Flesh nah man that can't be you get it
yeah is definitely uh humanizes them
like I see the how human they are of
course they're human like you and I I
mean they can yeah he turned their world
upside down and isn't it interesting the
first recorded instance guys the first
recorded
instance of any of his disciples calling
him God is Thomas
and it's after the Resurrection the week
after he rose John
20:28 prior to that if they did say he
was God it's not recorded the first
recorded instance of a
disciple confessing and testifying
Jesus's God is Thomas but he did it a
week after Jesus's
resurrection when he says my Lord and my
God now it sinks in
yeah those glimpses that we saw whereby
we thought he was claiming of God yeah
we yeah he was he indeed is and why were
they now comfortable to say right now
why are they okay with it and they have
no problem with it and they don't
disagree with it because he's been
raised from the dead Immortal in a
glorified physical body of Flesh that
now convinced them that yes he did claim
to be God no we didn't misunderstand and
no he's not blaspheming because if he's
a blasphemer he'd remain
dead see how that works
yeah
um what's your other question
so uh so basically what I was going to
ask
is by the way now before you ask you
know it's ironic you guys want to see
what's funny
Jesus's enemies get it he's claiming to
be God which is why they want to kill
him because they're now convinced he's
blaspheming is that ironic yeah I I
remember I forgot which passage it is
it's it's when uh they're they're
they're about to Stone him and there's
like I think in the New World
Translation it
says um no we're stoning him because we
claim you claim that you are God y yeah
here look now isn't IR onic even Jesus's
enemies got it this man who's not the
father's claiming to be God he's a man
blasphemy they're getting it but whereas
the disciples don't want to believe he's
blaspheming the enemies who hate him
have no hesitation he's blaspheming you
guys see the difference the disciples
who love him don't want to believe he's
blaspheming there's no way he's too good
too pure too loving too humble for us to
believe a blasphemy that can't be
there's no way his enemies who hate him
oh blasphemy here they're getting it
John 568 they're getting that he's a man
who's not the father who makes himself
equal to the father and therefore God
but they're wrong and thinking he's
blaspheming here John
51618 and for this reason the Jews were
persecuting Jesus because he was doing
these things on the Sabbath but he
answered them my father is working until
now and I myself am working
for this reason therefore the Jews were
seeking all the more to kill him because
he Not only was breaking the Sabbath but
also was calling God his own father
making himself equal to God so they're
getting it and they think it's blasphemy
the disciples are seeing it but they
don't want to believe it's blasphemy so
they have to say
nah here's another one John 10:30 33 I
and the father are one the Jews picked
up stones again to Stone him Jesus
answered them I showed you many good
works from the father for which of them
are you stoning me the Jews answered for
a good work we do not Stone you but for
blasphemy because you being a man make
yourself God see